[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravi de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du cahier cool le
magazine qui vous raconte les aventures
économiques du territoire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines nous sommes
attrape sur le site de l'entreprise
lrmann Titon cette société est
spécialisée dans la conception et la
fabrication de pièces plastiques à
destination des activités industrielles
elle a une implantation ici à trappe
mais aussi à Coignières et au total 250
personnes travaillent à 50 ans en
Yvelines pour l'entreprise lrman Titon
le 12 mai dernier elle a inauguré son
excenter un centre de recherche et de
développement de l'entreprise c'est ce
dont nous allons parler dans ce skyco
avec aussi la stratégie de l'entreprise
en attendant voici le sommaire de ce 48e
numéro la start-up l'officine du monde
est incubé au sein du ski cube spéci
dans la pharmacologie à la développer
trois gammes de produits à base d'une
plante la nigelle le groupe lrman title
est implanté à Saint-Quentin en Yvelines
depuis 30 ans spécialisé dans la
fabrication de composants plastiques
elles développent son activité de R&D à
travers son texte Center enfin
l'événement horizon cyber à
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines a permis de
rappeler l'importance stratégique des
enjeux de la cybersécurité l'occasion de
faire le point sur les activités du
groupe Thalès dans ce domaine vous
souhaitez créer votre start-up ou
accélérer votre projet entrepreneurial
le si cube lance sa campagne d'appels à
candidature du 25 octobre au 25 octobre
vous pouvez candidater pour rejoindre
l'incubateur 50 chinois à travers son
programme d'accélération ou d'incubation
et d'ailleurs à ce propos une réunion
d'information est organisée le 15
novembre prochain à 11h au ski cube et
parmi la trentaine de startups
actuellement accompagné au ski cube il y
a Odelia cette entreprise a développé
une gamme de compléments alimentaires et
de cosmétiques rencontrent avec son
fondateur Olivier Decazes dans la
séquence ma vie d'entrepreneur
je m'appelle Olivier decaze je suis le
fondateur de l'officine du monde qui est
une marque de complément alimentaire et
cosmétique à base de nigelle mes bureaux
sont situés à 50 ans en Yvelines
l'entreprise a été créée en avril 2021
[Musique]
nigelle c'est une plante ancestrale
qu'on consomme au quotidien depuis plus
de 3000 ans notamment à Babylone on en a
retrouvé dans la tombe de Toutankhamon
elle appartient aux plantes qui sont
recommandées en usage quotidien pour le
bien-être la santé et les soins
cosmétiques et capillaires depuis plus
de 1300 ans
[Musique]
il se trouve que je viens de l'univers
des cosmétiques et des grands groupes
français de la cosmétique et au cours
d'un voyage à Dubaï j'ai entendu parler
de cette plante et j'ai entrevue assez
rapidement ça résonnance mythique j'ai
cherché une personne qui connaissent
parfaitement la nigelle c'est là que
j'ai rencontré la personne qui allait
devenir mon associé qui est une
pharmacie française diplômée de Paris
Saclay mais aussi égyptienne
franco-egyptienne et l'idée ça a été
donc de développer une gamme de haute
qualité
[Musique]
nous avons quatre sources de nigelle
nous avons une nigelle qui vient d'Inde
nous en avons une qui vient d'Éthiopie
d'Égypte ou de Tunisie ou la
transformons en France nous la
conditionnons
[Musique]
nous avons trois gammes une gamme que
nous appelons indispensables une gamme
santé et une gamme où nous avons que des
huiles nous sommes dans un certain
nombre de pharmacies nous sommes dans 11
pharmacies aujourd'hui un peu dans toute
la France à Lille en banlieue parisienne
les au-delà de la France nous avons un
projet qui a vocation allait à
l'international
vous venez de le voir sur ces images et
leur mandaton a inaugurer le 12 mai
dernier son nouveau centre de recherche
et de développement sur le site de trap
c'est le Tex Center qui est composé de
trois presses innovantes un
investissement de près de 1,4 millions
d'euros et on va rejoindre tout de suite
Grégoire Renault le directeur général
delermann Titon France pour en parler
bonjour Grégoire Renault bonjour Nicolas
[Musique]
alors est-ce que vous pouvez me dire
quelle place à lrman title ici à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines c'est toutes
les activités françaises sont ici à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines absolument sur
le plateau de 50 ans en Yvelines où on
est depuis 30 ans maintenant en fait
notre 30e anniversaire ici sur place
sachant qu'il a maintenant France a 60
ans et donc on a à peu près 250
collaborateurs sur différents bâtiments
donc ici à Trappes où on est à peu près
200 et on a une trentaine de
collaborateurs sur notre entrepôt
logistique à Coignières toujours sur le
sur Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et alors
vous c'est de l'industrie vraiment de
précision parce que finalement vous êtes
sur des
outils des instruments critiques de
secteurs industriels oui alors tout à
fait déjà quand on dit industriel il
faut bien comprendre l'industrie au sens
large c'est à dire qu'on a des donneurs
d'ordre et des partenaires commerciaux
dans l'automobile dans l'aéronautique le
ferroviaire le naval etc
ce qui fait que on va pouvoir livrer des
pièces à du Dassault à des
constellations de satellites à des
constructeurs automobiles que vous
connaissez aussi bien que moi donc c'est
très varié et on est sur des exigences
spécifiques assez élevées que ce soit
sur le type de matériaux que l'on
utilise sur des résistances en
mécaniques en température en acoustique
etc on le voit sur ces images c'est
vraiment des petits composants alors non
pas électroniques mais des composants en
plastique qui permettent de maintenir
des câbles c'est ça alors tout à fait
nous ce sont des pièces plastiques qui
vont permettre de fixer de protéger
d'identifier les fils électriques les
câbles donc les faisceaux mais également
des tubulures dans lesquels passent des
fluides et en fait les pièces plastiques
peuvent avoir différentes tailles ça
peut être des colliers de serrage de une
dizaine de centimètres jusqu'à des
grandes goulottes qui vont porter des
faisceaux électriques et qui peuvent
mesurer jusqu'à un mètre et demi de
mètres alors avant de rentrer dans les
détails on va revenir tout de suite sur
cette inauguration le dernier à ce
moment là Andrew Leyland le président de
larmon title du groupe et l'armagne
title était venu ici pour inaugurer les
machines qu'on voit dernière nous on va
l'écouter d'abord et puis après on
rentrera dans les détails on les coupe
tout de suite
[Musique]
en France représente une part importante
du groupe et leur mandaton dans le monde
la France a de vrais atouts dans
différentes industries mondiales
[Musique]
ce centre de R&D est situé dans cette
zone d'innovation et de technologie
nous pouvons donc travailler étroitement
avec ses clients
[Applaudissements]
dans le monde
de la pandémie nous avons décidé que
l'élément le plus important pour et
leurs mind title et de se focaliser sur
l'innovation et maintenant cet
investissement montre que nous
continuons à investir et à supporter
l'innovation et la technologie pour la
France et pour les sites en Europe et
dans le monde
cet investissement nous assure la
possibilité de fournir des solutions
innovantes
et nouvelle pour rester au dessus des
autres entreprises
une des spécificités c'est LA CHAMBRE
BLANCHE des environnements sains dans
laquelle nous pouvons développer des
solutions
c'est le cas pour l'industrie médicale
et agroalimentaire où vous avez besoin
de haut niveau de qualité
ce qui va contribuer au succès du groupe
dans le monde entier
[Musique]
voilà
on vient de le président du
groupe title voilà il était venu pour le
texte Center il a fait le déplacement
c'est que c'est très important quand
même pour lrman Titon le texte Center
alors oui tout à fait ce centre tout
nouveau de recherche et de développement
vous voyez c'est très propre parce que
on a trois presses complètement
nouvelles après c'est injecter du
plastique de 60 tonnes 100 tonnes et 200
tonnes où on va pouvoir travailler en
environnement sale grise voire même sale
blanche donc on est sur des exigences en
termes de particules et de pollution
assez élevée et ce texte Center va
pouvoir nous aider à travailler en
innovation pour mieux servir encore nos
clients par rapport à des besoins qu'ils
ont déjà exprimés et des besoins qui
n'ont pas encore exprimé et on va aller
leur faire comprendre de façon à se
différencier par rapport à la
concurrence et justement garder notre
activité ici sur 50 ans en Yvelines
alors par rapport à ce texte Center
quels sont les objectifs à la fois
stratégiques et technologiques ok alors
en lien avec le texte Center notre
ambition c'est de développer des
nouvelles pièces
votre première objectif donc ça va nous
permettre de tester des nouveaux design
des nouveaux moules des nouvelles
matières ça c'est vraiment très
important on va être encore plus
respectueux de l'environnement donc des
nouvelles matières
des nouveaux processus on travaille sur
les réglages que après on va pouvoir
dupliquer à notre
outil industriel à notre centre de
production ce sont des présélectriques
donc pas hydrauliques donc c'est mieux
pour l'environnement et effectivement en
premier lieu on va pouvoir utiliser une
partie de nos rebroyés qui viennent de
la production donc ce sont de la matière
plastique qui n'a pas été utilisée ou
qui a été utilisé mais qu'on peut
réutiliser une nouvelle fois et on va
pouvoir faire des des essais grâce à ses
presses là pour réutiliser cela après en
production et être moins consommateur de
matière et donc d'énergie alors le texte
Center c'est finalement un nouvel outil
dans la R&D delermann title R&D est déjà
présente avant ce text Center alors oui
et c'est un de nos avantages très fort
parce que France nous avons un bureau de
recherche et de développement de design
on a recruté l'année dernière et on
prévoit de recruter encore l'année
prochaine pour développer nos
compétences en matière de développement
avec beaucoup de recherches associées et
en lien avec l'innovation qui vient de
des piliers dans le groupe et hormone
Titon et en quoi consiste les activités
de R&D dans ce type d'activité c'est
quoi c'est la conception des pièces
alors ça va être la conception des
pièces ça va être aussi l'optimisation
du design des moules ça va être
également l'utilisation des de matières
plastiques à recycler ça va être aussi
voir dans quelle mesure des nouvelles
matières
polyamide entre autres mais pas que
peuvent être incorporés dans les
produits que l'on propose à nos donneurs
d'ordre donc voilà c'est un petit peu
tout ça que le texte enter va nous
permettre de faire alors on comprend
bien donc c'est presque permettent
d'améliorer ce que vous faisiez déjà
avant
tout à fait ça va nous permettre
d'améliorer significativement ce que
l'on faisait avant mais également
d'adresser de nouveaux marchés comme je
décrivais précédemment on va pouvoir
travailler en environnement sale grise
salle blanche et donc aujourd'hui on
adresse de nouveaux marchés médical
paramédicales l'agroalimentaire les
énergies renouvelables les champs
d'éoliennes les champs de panneaux
solaires notamment alors justement on va
aller rejoindre Arly Da Costa qui est
chef d'équipe de production et découvrir
justement les machines qui fonctionnent
actuellement à côté de ces trois presses
derrière nous parfait merci
bonjour Arly bonjour Nicolas
on va voir le site de production c'est
ça bien sûr
alors Arly on vient de rejoindre le site
de production où est-ce qu'on est ici on
voit des j'ai l'impression que c'est des
coffres forts derrière vous on peut dire
ça mais non c'est pas tout à fait ça
c'est vraiment ici la grosse base
importante de chez l'hermann Petit tonne
on est dans l'atelier d'outillage les
outillages c'est les moules qui ensuite
sont transférés dans des presses
injections c'est ce qui permet de
fabriquer les pièces à injecter
c'est-à-dire que les moules prennent la
forme des petites pièces plastiques que
vous produisez donc ici ce qui se passe
actuellement tous les moules que vous
voyez c'est les moules qui sont en
entretien qui sortent l'atelier
d'injection qui viennent ici on les
entretient on les répare si faux on
changeait les électeurs on les nettoie
pour qu'il puisse ensuite repartir vers
l'atelier d'injection quand on en aura
besoin merci arlid Da Costa de rien
merci Nicolas je rappelle que vous êtes
donc chef d'équipe de production chez
elarman title à Trappes le 19 octobre
dernier les acteurs de la cybersécurité
se sont réunis sur le campus de l'ESTACA
à Montigny-le-Bretonneux durant
l'événement horizon cyber ce rendez-vous
permet d'échanger sur les questions de
la cybersécurité l'occasion pour nous
des interviewer Emmanuel dotaro il est
président du FC bersécurité au sein de
systématique et aussi VP chez felo
Thalès
Emmanuel dotaro je travaille chez Thalès
et mes activités concernent deux grands
sujets la cybersécurité et de les
infrastructures numériques dont les dans
les réseaux en particulier
des systèmes et des systèmes critiques
en général du système où les vies
humaines peuvent être en jeu et donc le
niveau de sécurité ces systèmes et de
façon indispensable forcément élevée on
ne peut pas développer la technologie
pour faire de la vie unique dans un
avion avec la sûreté des commandes de
vote sans se poser la question de la
cybersécurité on peut pas se poser la
question depuis l'otage de système
industriel critique dans le domaine du
nucléaire par exemple sans se poser la
question de la cybersécurité et il y a
une partie pure de cybersécurité ou la
cybersécurité se vend sous forme de
produits ou de services un encourt est
un de étant de nos socles des endroits
où on opère la cybersécurité tous les
gens peuvent externaliser ou profiter
des compétences d'un acteur qui est qui
suit au jour le jour les menaces et les
solutions de cybersécurité et donc une
partie de ces de ces opérations la plus
grosse partie historique est à Élancourt
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi vous pouvez la revoir en
replay sur notre site Internet ou sur
l'application mobile à bientôt sur TV 78
[Musique]